laughs
hello everyone welcome to rational
science the only site on the internet
that does physics rationally
today we're going to be looking
everybody else the movement of Concepts
and so on so that's not physics physics
is how do things how does the universe
work how does Mother Nature do her magic
tricks especially all that invisible
intangible stuff uh that's out there
magnetism gravity and so on you know you
can't see it you can't touch it but
somehow it works Clockwork Universe you
know anyways how does he do that that's
what physics is about figuring that out
the visible stuff the tangible stuff
we've already figured all those things
out those are kids stuff it from now you
know first have been for a long time but
uh the intangible invisible stuff that's
different that's that has all the
mathematicians going nuts they just do
equations anyways today we're going to
be talking about angle
what in the world is an angle
well it turns out that the
mathematicians don't seem to know
exactly what an angle is
then we're going to look at our science
critic and he doesn't seem to know what
a hypothesis is
he talks about
testing a hypothesis
how in the world do you test a
hypothesis well we'll find out about
that later anyways then I'll open the
floor for questions people who ask
questions or make comments since last
time but we're going to begin with our
segment our Extinction segment and by
the way uh yesterday I had a
little discussion with the people at
infernales small group of people but uh
they are you know they're they're
rationalists they try to be as rational
as possible and uh we talked about
Extinction and I mean you know there
it's just a complex subject very complex
you got to go through many aspects of it
and we covered quite a few of them so if
you're interested you know there's there
it is on my other channel the bill gatie
Channel okay but here we're going to
start with uh with Extinction as we
usually do and as you all know there's
there's this balloon war war going on
forget about nukes that's kids stuff now
we have all these balloons these uh you
know threatening balloons and
um I don't know maybe that starts the
balloon War they start throwing balloons
at each other uh I don't know I don't
know how that's gonna work out but uh
all I can tell you I think I figured it
out how what why the Chinese are sending
balloons over to the West okay and I
think it's got to do with this you know
you have the U.S blacklisting some
Chinese companies that made parts for
that balloon that flew over the first
one I flew over and I think the Chinese
are sending the balloons so that they
can sell the West
you know the uh the things to pinch them
with to pop them with the pins
so if you're in the habit of buying pins
all you're doing is you know uh you're
you're supporting the war effort the
balloon War right so I think that's what
Chinese are up to they're trying to sell
pins to the west and so they sell these
balloons so that they use them to pinch
them great okay but uh well who knows
maybe maybe we'll figure out what those
balloons are for you know uh I got my my
worries about it because on the one hand
you know you say well why would they
send balloons you know I mean we've got
satellites that can uh make images
of you know match boxes on the floor you
know on the ground and uh so I have no
idea yet why they would send balloons
but I'm sure that in the next
a few days or a few weeks uh they're
probably gonna figure it out and have
some theories and we'll find out we'll
find out what that's all about the
balloon War okay anyways but uh there's
another thing another type of War maybe
a little more conventional war that
might even lead to nuclear war you know
that's going on not in Ukraine but in in
the East you know with China and here
you have a couple of uh headlines that
puts it in the right perspective one
says that predicts the US dollar
dominance will give way to a multi-polar
currency system as China's Yuan gains
influence and you know they're starting
to do some transactions in yuan's and I
guess some people like that in in other
parts of the world right other than the
United States they like it because they
believe that
um United States if it has inflation and
can control its money supply
and that affects everybody else's who's
pegged to the dollar that's one issue
the other one is that the United States
uses that as a pressure point for
someone who doesn't behave the way the
U.S government wants and some of these
countries they they want to wean
themselves you know out of that they
want to be able to have a little more
discretion and uh in their monetary
systems and so I think that to some
degree that's probably going to be true
I think the yuan is going to be eating a
little bit into the dollar market and
maybe even the Euro might eat into it as
well so we'll find out how that develops
but I think we might be headed towards a
uh bipolar uh currency You Know Two
Worlds
we'll have to wait and see what happens
with that and there are other currencies
out there like the brakes and so on you
know so um don't put it past them uh
politicians are probably working in
different parts of the world are
probably working uh to solve their own
problems and that might mean that they
might have to wean themselves from the
dollar
uh the other one is uh a little more
you know worry some firewatch is America
going to war with China
you know and uh there is this
possibility that
um there's gonna be a war in the East
some predict that it's going to be
within two years
okay that uh and the trigger point was
very likely going to be Taiwan right
maybe there's going to be another flash
point who knows uh maybe someone attacks
a ship
on the China Seas you know uh that uh
some people claim it's uh should be
um International and China claims it's
theirs it's their personal Lake you know
and so we'll see what happens with that
same thing happened hundreds of years
ago between you know the uh Ottoman
Empire uh and together with the West you
had uh you know uh different countries
Spain especially you know and the
Munitions and they had these fleets and
they kind of uh all use the
Mediterranean see and the question was
who's who did that Lake belong to that
it belonged to the Ottomans the Turks or
do do they belong do they do does the
Mediterranean belong to the West you
know and so we've had a little bit of
history on on that issue and we'll see
what happens in China anyways here's
another bit of news that also puts uh in
perspective what might happen in the
coming months or years okay and when we
say months you know there's only 12
months to a year so we can say that in
24 months something might happen that's
two years so yeah you can talk in terms
of months if you're talking about a war
starting in two years okay so nothing
wrong with that and uh it says Wake Up
Call top Republican sound alarm over
China's nuclear expansion there are
several articles on that from different
sources China surpasses us in a number
of ICBM launchers and uh the U.S
military says China now has more ICBM
launchers than it does but the U.S still
has nuclear Edge okay and so I guess the
Chinese are using some of that money
that they're getting from their sales of
manufacturing products they're using it
for military purposes and you know
that's that's not good for anybody I
mean it's probably good for the Chinese
but it's not even good for them for
anyone ready to stock up on icbms
I mean are those icbms just there for
threat for
um
mad you know Mutual shared destruction
to
prevent the other side from throwing
them first or doing something along
those lines or is it actually to use
them at some point
you know you would think that uh every
country has at some point used the
weapons that it develops
but you know when you talk about nuclear
weapons you're talking about you know
real weapons now
okay we're not talking about a little
pop gun there and so you know you got to
think about that if everybody's arming
themselves uh you've got Russian United
States or you're going to stop that
start uh treaty and so instead of
starting it or stopping it's gonna be
the stop treating and who knows what
that'll bring and then you'll also have
uh the possibility of bringing down
satellites okay uh you have killer
satellites so it's gonna be a lot of fun
if any of those weapons ever get used
you know if they're just for deterrent
well okay no problem you know they they
just sit at a table reach an agreement
we're all fine but if they do a little
more than that then we better start uh
believing in God for the first if you're
an atheist right
okay and because of that you know
they've been putting that Doomsday Clock
back and forth you've got the UN Chief
okay he says Secretary General who
Darius uh said experts who surveyed the
static the state of the world in 2023
set the Doomsday Clock at 90 seconds to
midnight now that doesn't mean that in
90 seconds you know the world comes to
an end it's just uh you know uh
figurative you know that they move that
clock that hand on the clock closer or
farther away from 12 noon right the
closest ever to the global catastrophe
okay so we're as close as ever a minute
and a half away whatever that means
right I don't know if that represents
months or God's seven days you know
maybe they were a million years each who
knows
um he pointed to the war in Ukraine
right runaway climate catastrophe I
think that's nonsense Rising nuclear
threats that's not nonsense
the widening Gulf between the world's
haves and have-nots and I think there is
an issue there right that you got to
look at and the Epic geopolitical
divisions okay so yeah there are uh
divisions uh the world is kind of cut in
half now or maybe in third two three
thirds you could say Russia China and
United States unless you put China and
Russia together
and I'm not sure that's 100 percent
if it is at all you know it's like they
shake hands but they hold a knife behind
their backs and they're ready to stab
each other that's happened so many times
remember Russia and China were both
Communists at some point in time and
they were big enemies he said who did
they've got the same communist ideals
and so on how come their enemies well
because their ideals don't always match
their interests
and so it doesn't always go one-to-one
okay anyways uh these are some of the
things that are moving the clock closer
to
um
12 o'clock
which is uh doomsday and of course they
forgot the most important one and I'm
not sure how many seconds that's we're
away from 12 noon on that and that is
the global economic collapse and you can
see that's not even on the list and I
think the global economic collapse will
probably I can't put my hand in the fire
for this okay but we'll probably precede
any nuclear exchange I mean when when
the global economy collapses they may
not they may not see any reason to hold
back on the nukes
and they might start pressing the red
buttons that's one possibility in other
words they'll hold off
use it only as deterrents only at until
the point where the economy World
economy collapses nobody has anything to
lose anymore and then they say oh what
the hell
let's look at the fireworks maybe it's
one one angle to this angle I know
that's what I'll be talking about today
okay here's uh another issue uh America
is 31 trillion debt is getting dangerous
as yearly interest crosses 500 billion
mark
okay just the yearly interest is 500
billion some countries don't even make a
tenth of that
now their whole GDP is not 50 billion
and here you're talking about 10 times
as much
and of course that causes inflation
means that they have to produce more
money and you can see why some countries
want to stay away from the dollar if
they can help it partly because of that
Trend that you see there the dollar is
you know they're just producing uh money
out of the little machine
you know and that the values the dollar
and you say well what's the problem we
can continue doing that forever
not quite and the reason you can't do
that forever is that devalues the salary
the the real uh wages of the proletariat
of The Working Man the person who
depends on a salary or a wages
it devalues his money and also in the
money that uh the governments give out
to lots of people who depend on
government help to stay afloat so you
have this mass of people who are below
the oil you could say in the poverty
poverty regime in the poverty level and
the number came out the other day 38
percent of Americans are on in that
level that's pretty big percentage
almost two-fifths of the population is
in the you could say poverty level
if if that's what you want to call low
income okay whatever that means but more
people from the middle classes from the
medium income will be falling into that
range if you keep producing money like
they're producing it now with all this
debt okay and you can't just reset and
say uh okay we're going to change the
money we're going to reset all this uh
you got to pay the debts if you don't
pay the debts a lot of people will go
under a lot of companies will go under
who loan money and uh who are expecting
to have their money back
you know so you just can't say well
we'll just wipe it off the boats we'll
red ink it
uh it doesn't work that way so is you
can't just change green money with brown
money on sale let's continue rolling no
it's got repercussions and you just got
to think about that a little bit maybe
do a little bit of research on that but
let me tell you it's not as easy as just
wiping it off the books
accounting books
okay uh just in case uh here's one fell
at least who predicts there's going to
be a major stock market crash
in the coming months maybe coming years
talks about in the next few decades
I'm not sure it's going to happen in
decades I think it's going to be closer
to months and years than to decades
that's my take on that just a gut
feeling
and uh yeah I think the global economy
is headed to some kind of catastrophe
some uh crash
and not only the global economy you can
see you know it could happen in the
stock market a lot of them are
interrelated
okay and as you will I'll talk in a
second here a couple people think that a
lot of that is just collusion
between governments you know that
they're all shaking hands in the
background keeping the sheeple you know
down at the bottom
uh in the dark
feeding them misinformation Etc of
course there's a lot of that I'm not
saying there's there's not but but uh
for them to shake hands
um I'm not so sure about that that's
where I don't go 100 with that I don't
think uh Russia China are friends of the
United States I don't think that all
these people are working in the
background reaching agreements in closed
doors and say oh let's laugh at all
those little ants below they don't know
what we're doing up here I don't think
that's happening I think that the
killing is real you know uh in Ukraine
and I in other places as well where
there's confrontation but uh more than
that I think that uh they are really
enemies and I think their actions
demonstrate that the the reality you can
see it in in the fact that
um because of the Ukraine war the United
States has essentially taken over Europe
and Europe is now subservient to the
United States in many ways uh where they
have to follow the directions that are
coming out of uh Washington right and uh
they have to play along
the alternative is not too good either
they they might fall into the hands of
Russia or or have problems with Russia
and so they sided with the United States
because they said look we have more or
less the same philosophy and those
people over there they don't and so
that's that's the State of the Union of
the world Union right of how the world
runs today so I don't think there's a
agreement behind closed doors and part
of the the reason I think that is that
everybody has interest every country has
interests and not all those interests
are in the same direction okay they
collide
and so there has to be disagreement okay
and and I'm a guy who believed for many
years in the world government I don't
think that's ever going to happen no way
not there's not going to be a world
Empire where there's only one government
I don't think so not anymore it was my
goal a long time ago when I was 20 when
I didn't know when I knew everything now
I know nothing
okay and last uh issue here Mr Biden
says uh or made a comment they're
suggesting or insinuating that maybe
after 10 years the United States will
also wean itself off of oil or start
weaning itself off of oil and he
received a lot of slack for that a lot
of I guess the experts uh and immediate
and lots of Republicans of course uh
they started chipping on you know on
that issue saying he's crazy you know uh
energy is going to be required not only
Beyond 10 years beyond the 30s 2030s but
all the way to 20 050 in fact uh they're
saying the consumption is going to
increase if anything
and so you figure it out uh I think you
cannot uh
imagine that we can live without uh you
know oil energy whatever you want to
call it the Black Gold
um
for a long time to come uh I think the
world uh econ economic collapse is going
to find us still using lots of oil
that's my personal take on that I don't
think we're going to wean ourselves out
of oil and I'm not only saying the
United States all countries they all
depend to a great extent on this black
gold you know coming out of the ground
although all them dinosaurs
actually more from the Carboniferous but
and there were no dinosaurs then anyways
uh here's one uh visitor he says the
phone he says the premise that humans
will tear each other apart during a
famine or other crisis is just an
assumption yeah okay we have many
historical examples and what happened
was complicated people will calmly
starve to death next to their neighbors
and loved ones
yeah this is true and uh a good example
of that is uh the um uh when when uh
Hitler invaded Russia you know and um
they had a Siege on Leningrad the
Leningrad she The Siege you had a
population of over 2 million people and
they were you know they were trapped and
food started running out and you know
there were a lot of military there
because of the whole Russian big Russian
army was there defending the city but
um as far as I know I mean I don't know
the details but there were no uh uh
stealing I mean in great numbers right
maybe there was a case here or there
just like in any City but I mean not
everybody went out there and started
stealing not everybody started got out
there and started killing in fact a lot
of people cooperated they went into the
streets they shoveled uh whatever they
needed to shovel like make crunches or
whatever was needed or even get rid of
the dead bodies you know or if the
Germans bombed some of the uh uh houses
they would go and help people and so on
so there was a lot of that but I want to
distinguish that right where money was
still useful
from from a world in which money
collapses completely disappears from
people's minds because they nobody
accepts money and so you can't get rid
of money now you got a different
situation because you can't go to the
store uh to the uh Bakery and buy buy
bread
that's that disappears that that easy
stuff that we have today where we have
these bills or or even the phones or
whatever all this uh internet money and
it goes to someone and you buy something
you know that easy stuff that gets
vanished uh completely out of our world
and what we have then is lack of food
because no one produces or distributes
food you can't use your money and now we
have a different situation
and the question there is are you just
going to sit down maybe with your family
yeah uh will you sit down with all your
neighbors will all your neighbors think
the same way as you do and again I
showed the other day uh next to know
that again the Twilight Zone uh segment
where this guy builds a a little uh
basement there you know he's got a place
where to hide uh in case the bombs are
thrown and all his neighbors who knew
about it they just tried to break into
his little
uh Castle there underneath the ground so
uh you have situations and situations
and I'm saying that when money
disappears uh
uh you better not trust anyone
my five cents worth okay your point is
that other humans are not necessarily
loyal to you so you should be loyal to
them uh yeah it's a question that
um if you went back to the Paleolithic
when we were hunter-gatherers uh humans
didn't trust humans any more than a lion
tries to another lion
and because uh the only animal a lion
fears is another lion a male lion you
know why because uh he doesn't fear the
cheetah or you know uh I don't know
uh one of those dogs
or smaller animal whichever animal he
fears another lion because what he's the
king of the jungle whether that's true
or not you know so just think about that
you're your worst enemy is going to be
another human
so you might say well you know I know
these people across the street I know
the guy next door that could be true but
people who react very differently under
uh went under pressure when they're in a
different situation so just keep that in
mind uh uh thirty thousand forty
thousand fifty thousand years ago nobody
trusted anybody out there in the wild
because there was no law there was no
one to protect you you were your own
protection
okay and the other guy was tougher than
you you were out of luck you couldn't
call the Marines okay anyways but humans
can be loyal to others in spite of
Crisis look out for number one is not as
liberating as you might imagine yeah
it's not a question uh liking it it's
and I'm not saying liberating I'm saying
that it's uh like a necessity okay it's
like you can't avoid it unless you want
to be killed and you know by by your
neighbor and trust is in the eye of the
beholder if you believe that you should
trust your neighbor well more power to
you hopefully it helps you you know but
I'd be watching out when the global
economy collapses I would trust anybody
in fact today very few people know who
their next their neighbors are they
don't even know the names of who lives
next door sometimes uh he might be a
rapist or whatever the guy next door
killed or murder or maybe the law is
looking for him you don't know because
very few people uh not I can't say very
few people but lots of people out there
don't even know who their neighbors are
okay
so keep all that in mind Americans give
not Lee lend uh Israel billions of
dollars every year and it's none of our
business
I think it's fair to say we paid and
continue to pay for the right to
criticize
absolutely not okay first of all you're
not an American
okay I'm sorry to tell you this okay
you're not an American
you're a human being
you were brainwashed
to believe you're an American okay you
were brainwashed to believe that you're
a Russian you're a brainwashed to
believe you're a Chinese okay your brain
was since you're a kid to look at the
flag say the anthem that kind of thing
and root for the colors
you know we're humans that's all we are
that's that's objectively what we are uh
nationalism you know whether you're an
American is up here okay mother nature
doesn't know what you got inside your
head all she knows is that you're a
human being that's all you are
objectively to her okay so
um you know uh we say oh I'm gonna
defend my side against their side
okay and in this case fellow says you
know I don't like my money going to
Israel you know
but the issue is you know you're being
taxed you're confusing two issues here
okay let's get them straight
you're being taxed you have to pay taxes
because someone put a gun to your head
the government and they have ways of him
making you believe in the way they do
okay that you must pay your taxes pay
taxes and you will pay taxes all the way
to your until you die okay it's we we
know this this is the way it is so you
pay taxes
now whether whether that money goes to
help the children in Afghanistan or it
or or to help Israel
you don't have any say in that
you say sure I do no you don't you don't
have any say in that believe me you have
no say in it unless you you are a
representative you know or a senator
maybe then you have some say in it but
you as a constituent the guy who votes
you have no say in that whatsoever
okay and you might think you have power
you say I'm going to get to together
with all these other people who think
like me and say my money doesn't go over
there
it's going to go there if the Congress
decides which is a separate issue of you
being taxed these are two separate
issues you might say hey I voted for the
Democrats or I voted for the Republicans
because they would not help Israel
it turns out now these people are
helping Israel and I don't want my money
going out there
well the answer is what are you going to
do about it
are you going to go with a gun to to
Washington and force them not to give
money out to whoever they want to
whoever the Congress decides to give
money to I mean a lot of people don't
like to give money to Ukraine they say
it's a black hole you're just swallowing
money
but the government's doing it and so all
those people who are against it even if
they were majority
you know if the government decides that
it's in their best interest to help
Ukraine because of maybe uh National
Security issues
you know these small ants that say Hey
you know I don't want my daughter's
going out there they have no say in the
matter and it's got nothing to do with
taxes taxes is what you pay because
you're forced to pay decisions on where
that money goes that's with Congress and
uh just like anything else you know you
don't get to vote who goes to Congress
you get to in other words you don't
elect you see you vote for who is
selected for you okay whomever is
selected for you that's whom you have to
elect okay you don't get to select
and I hope you understood that
so uh that's why you know I get out of
politics politics is just sponsor
baloney
but it took me many years to figure a
lot of this stuff just don't get
involved in politics unless you are a
politician and you have some paralytics
yeah it's your career no problem and if
you can make money on the side do it as
well but to say that you as a just a
measly old voter who puts a casts a vote
for a candidate and expects them to do
what you want
think again
okay uh follow says here propaganda is
uh as news yeah there's a lot of that in
fact uh you know here I can't get
um
RT you know the Russian uh the channels
uh I just get the headlines and I don't
even know how I got that but uh I can't
read the uh the news and you know I
would like to read the news myself you
know I would like to compare what they
say on the other side compared to what
they say on this side of these this
dividing line Ukraine war for example
and I don't get to do that because
someone does it for me they said we're
not gonna let you listen to this side oh
okay uh called freedom of the press
right so yeah there's a lot of
propaganda as news okay uh the war in
Ukraine is one example Israel you know
uh yes it's is a pro Israel country uh
the pro-israel uh yeah that favors the
uh Israel uh because in a way Israel is
the fifth column of the United States
it's just another star in the flag okay
uh there's there's more than just a love
affair there there okay so it's Israel
would not be as powerful today if it
didn't have all the help from the United
States and so I hope you can figure that
out after what 1948 that's when Israel
became a country and if you go back to
you know what is it 1917 1919 I think it
was
um
um that I talked about the other day
you've got the um uh the creation of the
Israel state of Jews going into Israel
and eventually becoming a country and
pushing the Arabs further and further
out all that was pushed by the West
primarily by the United States so you
know the the West is very pro-israel and
that's just a fact of life okay so you
have to accept it whether you like it or
not okay that's why don't get involved
in politics because you might say ah but
look they're killing Palestinians or
whatever
it doesn't affect you
I'm sorry it doesn't affect you go
fishing get a beer you know have a good
time go with family then you'll enjoy
yourself if you think about what's going
on in other parts of the world your mind
is over there you're not paying
attention to what's going around you
think of it that way same way the lgbtq
the alphabet people you know that that
propaganda is going all over the place
it's propaganda as news so he's right
about that there's a lot of that going
on
um indoctrination as education yeah
especially nationalism like I said you
know nationalism we're all indoctrinated
in nationalism since you we are kids
okay so uh that's one of the biggest
also we have religion but I think one of
the biggest religions is nationalism man
that's ingrained in everybody uh they
they feed it to you since you're a kid
and you can't get rid of that so easily
you know you can't be neutral okay and
uh it's very hard for people to wean
themselves out of nationalism mind
control is entertainment yeah uh there's
a lot of games uh you have all these
kids you know getting all their
information from Tick Tock and so on uh
kids are hooked on that today so I'm
not sure if you can talk about mind
control but there is an element of a
herd mentality out there with this issue
and if you can call that mind control I
guess that's mind control okay
as well says in all nuclear war exchange
is impossible
uh I don't know why he says that it's
impossible nuclear exchanges is totally
possible everybody presses their red
buttons and we're done so possible it is
probable that's a separate issue whether
they actually will press those red
buttons that's a different issue but
possible is 100 possible it's just not a
hundred percent probable in fact
before the collapse of the global
economy is probably improbable
that's the way I look at it but again
you never know uh the State of Mind of
some of the heads of state
okay and governments are working
together in keeping their populations
under control through fear yeah I don't
think their governments are working
together I don't think Russia works
together with the United States at the
basic at the root level there is some
level of cooperation here and there uh
simply because of self-interest so they
reach agreements they do shake hands in
private you know they reach some kind of
treaty or whatever they sign treaties
but to say that they're all in cahoots
and collusion uh where they say Hey you
tell your people this we'll tell our
people that uh to some degree that's
true but not completely the way I think
this fell is proposing that they're all
in such collusion that uh all the rich
people are saying hey uh you know we're
we're on the same Club whereas all the
poor people are in a different Club
I think there is animosity I think there
is a state of war between the East and
the West okay I don't think that's fake
okay so but that's my personal take on
that uh you take my sense where my five
cents worth for what you think it is
worth it okay
uh well uh one more comment for another
visitor he said I researched those who
create conspiracy based videos trying to
debunk nukes there are many hours of
gathered evidence to the stories and uh
and some of them will make you question
things as they so obviously fake some
things okay just like some of the Moon
footage okay I don't know about that uh
maybe there is some I don't think it's
fake uh Moon footage I think sometimes
they put in there uh things that they
did in the lab they took pictures of
that or filmed something there and they
would put that maybe in an official
capacity
maybe because it looks better than the
film that they've filmed out there and
so people say oh I got you there you put
something that's fake yeah it is fake
because it just looks better and it's
served no purpose to put the real thing
which has less quality maybe something
like that happened I won't put that past
them but to say that humans did not land
on the moon that's a separate issue
that's that's got to be analyzed to a
different degree and my take on that is
that
um
if uh if if if you cannot show me okay
that whatever they could do on the moon
they could do in Hollywood and vice
versa
then you don't have a case
you have to show me that there's
something that they did one place that
they could do in the other
okay but if if everything on the moon
could be done in Hollywood you haven't
said anything you don't have an argument
okay because that means that you have no
way of distinguishing the real thing
from the fake one
if if everything that they did on the
moon could be done in Hollywood we have
no way of distinguishing between those
okay and so and the funny part is that
you know people who say that or who are
you that have that argument then they go
in there and they say oh but the Shadows
are wrong oh the stars in the background
are not there well you know they made so
many errors in Hollywood
these guys didn't know that the you know
Roman gladiator had a Rolex watch
you know you take that scene out and so
why didn't they take all these scenes
out that you know that all these people
who scrutinize those movies say ah
there's an error there's another error
they find so many errors you say well
you know who did these films
so no um all I can tell you is uh you
got to be able to distinguish between
Hollywood and the moon if you can't do
that you don't have a case Okay so
that's where you gotta it's not the
other way around like saying oh but they
could have done that on in Hollywood
yeah if they could have done it in
Hollywood you don't have a case because
that means that they did it all in
Hollywood and they could have done it in
in real life out there in the moon and
if you can't tell me what the difference
is then you don't have a case that's
that's an invalid argument okay so think
about that anyway it says the so-called
nuclear blast that side swipes the
buildings and decimates them yet
everyone fails to notice camera taking
the shots doesn't even shudder once from
the ground uh Tremors well you know uh
we're talking about something that's
very far away okay it's not like the
guys there you know stuck to the uh to
the Ground Zero you know the guy's far
away if you look at the blast um uh in
uh Alamogordo there in New Mexico uh
yeah they were far away they saw this
from very far away they they had an idea
of more or less what was going to happen
so they weren't just standing there next
to it they also used some special
glasses you know it's not like they were
staring directly at the flash so keep
all these things in mind they are far
away and how much of that vibrates the
ground well you know that's uh something
you got to look at is this like an
earthquake where it's underneath your
feet or an earthquake when you're a few
miles away
you know will you feel the Tremors okay
and I've been through three earthquakes
in California we had them over there in
Sunnyvale where I worked and the ground
shook yeah I know what an earthquake
looks like now three of them I went
through
uh blast of that magnitude has
supposedly been reported to set off
small earthquakes yeah uh small
earthquake
yeah it depends on how far away you are
so you know I'm not sure you said much
there unless you can tell me exactly how
far away you were or how far away you
should be from a nuclear blast and if
you put the camera there with a focusing
lens
you know you can film that without
having too many Tremors especially if
you're in some kind of uh platform that
you know protects against uh vibrations
so think about all that
okay let's move on to our uh segment of
um physics
and today we're going to look at angle
what is an angle you know I thought I
knew
but it turns out that um well I probably
know but I don't think the
mathematicians know
and we'll see some differences here so
let's start with our version uh this is
it okay I talked about the universal
movie Universal movie is a tool that we
use uh so that every frame in that film
in that in the Universal movie simply
shows all objects in the universe every
single atom at a given distance from
each other it's just separation
qualitative separation and everything is
standing still in each frame so in order
to see the universe move
just tiny amounts you know from one
location to the next but very you know
very tiny amounts in the location uh you
need to look at two frames or more and
two frames or more is what we call
motion and the concepts that you see at
the bottom there motion position plasma
ether Etc all those are Dynamic Concepts
you need at least two frames in the
Universal movie to conceptualize
anything that involves motion on the
other hand static Concepts as the ones
you see at the top the ones in yellow
there and blue those you can see in a
single frame are you can conceptualize
in a single frame
and there you see some object distance
location existence those are all static
Concepts you do not have to see anything
moving in order to conceptualize those
words
and one of them is lying as you can see
there you see a line which is an object
okay and what you're staring at is a
a an elongated rectangle
that's what you're that's what's
objectively in front of you okay so what
you look you're looking at something
standing still it's an object it's an
object because it has shape that's the
reason it's an object it looks like a
two dimensional could be three but at
least it's got two Dimensions right it's
got width and height okay there's no
length length would be the third
dimension on that okay at least we don't
see it there and what you see is an
elongated rectangle it's got four edges
okay etc etc
so um that's what a line is objectively
that's what's in front of you it's not
1D it's 2D okay and uh it's an elongated
rectangle which is what uh 2D is what
you have there is a plane that's
objectively what is in front of you okay
that's that's the starting point okay I
hope you understood what I just said one
follow says he goes through the motions
of uh trying to debunk that those ideas
and here's the first notion he puts out
he says online has a straight path
uh-huh on a plane that extends forever
in both directions with no end points
a line segment is part of a line
so a line is one thing a line segment is
something else it's a part of a line a
segment of a line right that has two
endpoints n is finite in length okay I
hope that makes sense to some of you
okay a ray is a line segment that
extends indefinitely in One Direction
these are conceptual one-dimensional
geometries meaning that they can only
reside in the mind or minds of humans as
abstract ideas
okay these geometric geometries then can
only be represented with illustrations
okay so this is his argument saying
that's what a line is the line is not
what I showed you just now which is an
elongated two-dimensional rectangle okay
he's saying something else
and so let's go piece by piece to see
what this fellow said okay so see if we
can detect all the errors he made
every single one that he made with his
description or identification of what a
line is okay here it is let's go with
the first one he says a line is a
straight path
uh well a path is not a figure
you know a path like there you have a
plane path right path uh made by a plane
uh this one's crooked it's not straight
okay but um if a path is not
um a figure it doesn't belong in
Geometry okay
um so a path is a noun in ordinary
speech and it's approximately or
something similar to a whole you need in
order to have a path you need some
ground for example right you need to
have some something on which you make
the past just like when you make a hole
you need to have the ground to make the
hole into not like in mathematical
mathematics you know mathematical
physics where they have these black
holes and they drill them into space and
they're Zero Dimensional let's hear a
dimensionable holes so you figure that
one out and so the this path which is a
verb actually right is an itinerary a
trajectory or orbit in case of orbit it
would be circular not straight right but
then you cannot talk about straight you
cannot use the adjective straight to
qualify a path because a path is not a
thing it's a verb okay as he used it
there
can it extend forever uh well then it's
not a figure again no figure extends
forever because a figure is that which
has shape okay so not only doesn't it
belong in um geometry uh but uh if it
extends forever it's not a figure
period and verse don't extend so if path
is a verb then it you cannot talk about
extending it like you would extend a
clothesline okay extends forever again
he's talking about an itinerary he's
talking about motion
uh there is no object that extends
forever whenever you talk about forever
meaning time
Eternal right or use any of those
qualifiers you're talking about not
extending you're talking about
um something different you're saying
that
um the itinerary
is uh never ending it's
um you know it just goes on and on uh
you could say forever right uh the
you're talking about motion you're
talking about perpetual motion and not
about a physical object
and no end points again not a figure so
all those he failed and that's just in
his first sentence okay so uh
uh there he had trouble uh qualifying
what a line is okay he's not he fails
all those uh points not a geometry not a
figure it's a verb and there's no uh
verb that extends and there's no object
that extends forever
so he failed all those
but he continues here he goes on a
second I said a line segment is part of
a line well we just held that a line is
not a figure so uh what is it part of an
itinerary I guess that's what he's
saying okay that has two endpoints and
is finite in length well we've got a
problem that because
um
you know if it's got two end points you
could say it's a line but if it's uh if
if it's just a segment of a line and a
line is a itinerary all you're talking
about is two locations those endpoints
are locations and what you have in
between are more locations you're
talking about an itinerary
so this line segment is actually a verb
that is conceptualizing there and it's
find that in length he says you know and
again uh verbs are not finite
okay motion is not finite all motion is
infinite if you use that term not
correct adjective you can say all verbs
are incessant every motion is incessant
okay and verbs don't have endpoints so
again all those issues he failed
um
in describing what a line is okay so
he's got the wrong Notions of what he's
what is objectively in front of you okay
and here's another one that says array
is a line segment that extends
indefinitely in One Direction well we
have a problem because he already
defined line segment as one that has two
endpoints
so now he's saying well it's a line
segment that does not that is missing
one endpoint
what was the line segment an itinerary
because it's a line and a line is as an
itinerary so the line is not a figure
which means a line segment is not a
figure which means a ray is not a figure
we're talking about verbs here okay line
segment is equal to two length endpoints
in other words that line summing can't
be extended indefinitely okay so again
he's got all these errors in
conceptualizing what a line is it's easy
to tear all his arguments down okay
and then he moves on to the next issues
which is the conceptual issue he says
these are conceptual one-dimensional
geometries meaning that they can only
reside in the mind or minds of humans as
abstract ideas but we have a problem
because a concept is not an object okay
so if if he's going to talk about
figures there's no such thing as a 1D
figure and if it's uh a 1D figure it
doesn't belong in geometry yeah you
can't illustrate the 1D so he's talking
about uh you know
um geometries can only be represented
with illustration yeah geometries can
but not the 1D line you cannot
illustrate uh a 1D line whatever you put
on the papers at least 2D too too
dimensional uh an idea is a concept is a
synonym of the word concept so there's
synonyms and so idea is not a figure and
again that means that it doesn't belong
in geometry so he made all these errors
in just a couple paragraphs couple
sentences there
uh very interesting you know because uh
it just about failed every single one
all I can ask him is that he do a little
bit of research and uh get the basics of
geometry because apparently he lacks an
understanding of geometry basis of
physics also right
uh here's the the correct definition
okay which I'll put up again what are
you staring at I mean objectively well
you see an elongated rectangle
and that a rectangle is straight you can
talk about straight you can qualify it
as straight because you use the
adjectives to qualify nouns
a line is a noun because it has shape
and for the purposes of physics purposes
of science okay that object there is an
elongated rectangle it's got four sides
two-dimensional
those sides have edges so it's got four
edges
it's got width and height
okay and you can say it's straight
because objects can be said to be
straight you can qualify them with that
adjective uh what else if it's straight
it's continuous continuous means it's
made out of a single piece not made of
parts
okay and in Contra and it's finite in
contrast
the line of mathematics which is what
this fellows apparently was trying to
describe or Define right is an infinite
line meaning there's no it's not an
object it's not a thing it's one D which
again it's not a thing you can't
illustrate a 1D what they're talking
about is an itinerary they're talking
about made of points meaning locations
what is made of locations motion two or
more locations makes motion Okay so
you can see that what they're and
especially if you get the infinite signs
there the negative two positive Infinity
they're now talking about a physical
object they're not talking about a
geometry a figure
so that's a line a line is what you see
there objectively that's what's in front
of you now if in your mind
they force you to say well yeah that's
what's there in front of you but think
of it as a 1D line
well now you're being subjected
now you're not talking about what's
objectively in front of you what's
coming out of the screen to your eyes
now you're interpreting that and saying
okay I'm going to imagine that's a 1D
line but you cannot even imagine a 1D
line because there is no such figure
in Geometry okay that's why they they
never try to that's why they can't
define the point the Zero D point and
the 1D line because they're not points
and they're not lines they're talking
about locations and they're talking
about motion
and they call that geometry so our
forefathers the Greeks they screwed up
from the start and I'm sure there were
people before them that where they got a
lot of this understanding of geometry
measurement measurement of the land okay
okay so now you know what a line is why
do we need the line well because we're
going to talk about angles
we're going to say well how does the
line relate to an angle does an angle
require lines
so that's going to be the issue right
remember what is a line just a elongated
rectangle in physics in science that's
what's objectively in front of us and we
look at it objectively no subjectivity
whatsoever no interpretation
in math they do something else they look
at that and say well you're not staring
on at a 2d line you're actually staring
at a 1D line meaning
points meaning that it's locations that
form motion that's what they're talking
about okay and that's a interpretation
that's subjective okay and that's where
the problem comes because what you're
staring at is not what they're
describing there's a you know they don't
match okay there's a disconnection there
okay so here we bring the universal
movie again okay and so for us it's very
simple what is an angle well you have
two lines okay and you have a separation
between them
see how easy it was that's what a angle
is they're connected at one point and
not at the other
okay so uh that's an angle
um problems come when they have Zero
Dimensional angles okay and um that's
one where the problem one of the
problems because you have the Zero
Dimensional angle and they say that's an
angle it's a Zero Dimensional angle well
now if you define it as connected at one
end and not at the other then it can't
be Zero Dimensional okay
so just keep that in mind but it's a
steady concept because we're looking at
the end result not on how we got there
and that's where you're going to see the
difference okay not how we got there but
the end result
a static concept you what's coming out
of the screen to your eyes
that that doesn't move it's in a single
frame of the universal movie what do you
see you see two lines that are separated
lines are physical objects you can
describe them as being straight okay
because you can use the adjectives such
as straight to qualify a line a
geometric line and what you're saying
that separation we call that an angle
okay we don't need to know by how much
by how many we don't need to measure we
don't need to use the word degrees
you don't need any of that in fact if
you go to another planet maybe they have
a different uh
notion of degrees maybe they don't use
the 364 uh you know a circle they don't
use 90 for uh perpendicular maybe they
don't use any of that maybe they have
other numbers for those same you know
relations
okay so um let's look at what an angle
is for these people okay and here's the
unimaginable mathematical so-called
physics angle
angle okay so that's what we're going to
look at now what is an angle well it's a
quantitative
uh concept it's how much that's what
they're interested in they're not
interested in the qualitative aspect of
this they're just interested in the
quantitative how much how much wide is
the mouth of the alligator you know
that's what they want to look at and
it's got to do with measurement numbers
units
degrees in this case could be radians
some other uh measure that you can come
up with
angle uh two 1D lines
what was the line in mathematics
motion
so you're saying that you need two
itineraries two trajectories straight
trajectory straight itineraries right
uh to make an angle according to
mathematical physics so-called physics
okay uh straight I don't know about
straight because uh itineraries cannot
be straight
you can say that
um a ruler is straight okay or the table
is straight you cannot say that you walk
straight
the word is rectilinearly I walk
rectilinearly then you can use the word
um this adverb to qualify a verb but you
can't say that walking is straight not
in physics in ordinary speech you can
say whatever you want that's poetry
that's good that's a hyperbole you can
use whatever you want there but in
physics in science you have to use the
correct language that's what we're
trying to teach here the correct
language and you can't say you walk
straight you work when you walk
rectilinearly that's the way you say it
in science
okay let's get that straight straight
okay and um they have the mathematical
line it's a rectum in your itinerary so
um to form an angle they use two
trajectories two itineraries
okay and really you should represent
those with dotted lines they never do
they what they have is these solid lines
which is wrong
because if they're going to talk about
itineraries what they're doing is
putting one itinerary at an angle with
respect to another itinerary
okay so they're talking about two
itineraries and is that an angle or or
do we need two objects to create this
pattern okay because remember when you
have motion the only way you can
reproduce that if you remember the
previous locations
otherwise you know you don't know if you
walk right straight and another person
walks straight in a different direction
right you formed an angle between the
two of you
but see the problem is that you're just
at the end points you have location only
at one place you can't be at two places
at once like in quantum mechanics okay
so you're here in one place the other
guy's over there at another place and
the only way you can remember you know
that you have an angle
is by tracing all the locations back to
square one to where you both from where
you both parted
okay so again when you talk about
itinerary you only end up at one
location finally and the only way you're
gonna get back is if you trace a line
through all those locations and unite
the two at a corner the two you know the
two itineraries that one corner so
that's the notion that they have in
mathematics okay and
even worse because they have one of
these trajectories
it rotates you know it opens up
so we have not only two trajectories
you're moving along these paths as this
fellow called it and then the
trajectories are widening out and
they're looking at that separation
so we have uh an itinerary that is
moving
and forming what an angle because that's
what the line is it's an itinerary it's
a it's not a line
it's not a rectangle an elongated
rectangle it's a bunch of locations and
once you build this location this set of
locations now you're gonna widen that
you're gonna fan it out to form your
angle so you have a whole bunch of
locations you got to finish that line
first right that that itinerary and now
you're going to move the whole itinerary
you're moving motion to form the angle
that's the end that's the notion they
have in mathematical physics
okay I hope that someone got that so
yeah an angle is rotation of a
trajectory
um
uh well rotational trajectory of
rectilinear trajectories
that's what it is you're rotating the
trajectory or the itinerary okay and uh
of course they're interested in degrees
or radians or whatever and uh that those
are measurements those are units and
those have to do with numbers with how
many
units of uh you know you create the a
number or a unit and then you say so
many units is what this moved over
and so they're talking about motion how
much something rotated not about the end
result
it the degrees is a measure of motion
a motion event of an itinerary so I hope
you got all that
uh what are some of the problems that
this creates these Notions these
Concepts that these people have of what
an angle is well here here let me give
you a couple examples here here's the
first one mathematical physics
perpendicular what is perpendicular well
we say it's an angle
okay
um and uh again perpendicular is a
quantitative Concept in mathematical
physics and invokes two directions
remember uh but here you're talking
about again motion okay the direction in
mathematical physics is not a static
concept it's Motion in a given Direction
and so we have directions that are
moving now okay so keep all that in mind
uh but direction is a qualitative
concept
I mean it doesn't even belong in math
okay so you'd you you have no use for
direction in math I can't put a
direction in an equation
okay but they do through velocity
because velocity has magnitude and
Direction okay but the direction part is
the qualitative part and they kind of
put it in by hand
you know acceleration if you change
direction like in an angular momentum or
angular uh rotation
um you accelerate even though even
though the speed remains constant you
accelerate simply by changing direction
a qualitative concept that changes your
acceleration which is a quantitative
concept okay keep all this in mind so
math direction is a dynamic concept okay
and this implies that mathematical
physics the perpendicular the notion
perpendicular is also a dynamic concept
so they're not talking about the final
result for perpendicular which is like
that they're saying that they're moving
the stick
that they put to represent Direction
motion right itinerary they're moving it
and that motion
is the 90 degree angle okay they have to
put a number to that and so you can see
they always represent it with arrows
okay and so here here you see a
comparison side by side okay the
physics perpendicular okay it's
perpendicular is qualitative
it's a static concept
okay we don't need to have anything in
moving perpendicular to something you
see in a single frame of the universal
movie perpendicular invokes the edges of
two straight ideal figures there you see
the picture of the blue versus the red
line
and a vertical figure versus a
horizontal figure that's what it is
that's a definition of perpendicular the
bird perpendicular comes from the plumb
bob that the Masons used to use in the
old days and it would put the plumb bob
to measure it against the Horizon okay
so they would build a wall and they want
to see if it was straight they would
hang something away from a string and
they would measure it would check to see
if this wall was straight it was all
qualitative there was no 90 degree for
that purpose all they said is it's uh
perpendicular what do you mean by that
well it's one is straight when is
vertical compared to the other one which
is horizontal that's what they meant and
that's what it is that's what it is for
the purposes of physics and that's what
is objectively in front of you okay this
other stuff that's on the left uh the
mathematical notion 90 degrees all that
that's for calculations that these
people want to do to play around you
know but then uh they come up with uh
idiotic absolutely idiotic
conclusions such that gravity is
geometry what do you mean geometry yes
the warping of this platform which are a
bunch of Dimensions which are a bunch of
number lines actually and we bend them
and uh it's the bending of space time
right
just this coordinate system that bends
and that's gravity
so you can see that it does have an
effect on the minds of all these
mathematicians who extrapolate the
Notions of geometry that they've created
to reach conclusions irrational
conclusions that you know rational
people out there have problems
swallowing they say what do you mean
space time what is space time well we
don't know it's it's unimaginable
because it's four dimensional oh it's
like a four-dimensional object yeah it
is space and time time is a physical
object well you don't have to take it so
literally those are the answers you get
and so yeah all these geometric figures
they come from these lines and points
which were misdefined from the start and
today if you look those words up they
say well we can't really Define these
words yeah they can't because they're
trying to Define
um
an object and you don't Define objects
you don't Define the word table you
don't Define the word Rock the word Tree
in science you point and say tree Rock
table
then you can describe it but you didn't
need to describe it to point and name it
you can't do that with a concept concept
you must Define rocks trees tables you
don't Define you just point a name and
so that's the difference okay object you
point to and name and Concepts you
define okay here's uh the wrap up on
that uh here you have the mathematical
physics dimension
what is the dimension well according to
mathematical physics okay this is the
mathematics version the minimum number
of coordinates needed to specify any
point within it and see they use these
words like point and coordinates and you
say oh what was all that well coordinate
is a number that's what it is you look
up the word coordinate and say it's just
a number so it ends up being a dimension
is just a minimum number of numbers
okay and then they say any point meaning
a location not a point they use the word
point and it's very misleading because
you don't know if they're talking about
a DOT or location and they're talking
about location they're not talking about
a point therefore point is not part of
geometry location is what they're
referring to and location is not a
geometric figure especially if it's
alleged to be Zero D which it ain't
because you have the because what they
have is like an ordered pair ordered
triplet how to get to that location this
the instructions on how to get there
that's what a point is the instructions
on how to get there not what it is
it's not the location itself is how to
get there instructions on how to find a
treasure chest
okay so we have the number of numbers
and what is the number it's to
that's what a number is
okay and so I'll let you think about
that for a long while but that's what
the word number is it's not a noun for
the purposes of science it's a noun in
ordinary speech but not in science in
science it's the verb to count that's
what county that's what number is
counting okay and so a dimension
coordinate vectors they're all Dynamic
Concepts
and they all have magnitude and
Direction they say vectors have but
they're all the same all three are uh
magnitude and direction
because they're talking about number
lines and number lines have magnitude
but they don't have Direction
actually
uh only physical things you can have
Direction okay and number lines have no
direction in great measure because
numbers can go in any direction you want
you know that way that way that way I
mean look at a number line called time
which direction does time flow or run or
whatever they say whatever word they use
to qualify that no time doesn't run or
flow in any direction because time is
not moving it's not a thing that moves
in any direction you can say the cow
moved in that direction you can't say
time moved in that direction
and time is a number line it only has
magnitude it has no Direction
is a qualitative concept belongs
exclusively to physics not at all to
mathematics okay so uh what are all
these Dimensions coordinates and factors
they're rectilinear trajectories in fact
you see there that's a typical
graph for uh
Cartesian coordinates and you can see
they put arrows and they're all chopped
into pieces
because what they're really representing
with those lines cut cut it cut into
segments you know what they're
representing is locations numbers each
one is uh identified with one number and
you can break those numbers up in
gazillions of pieces no problem you know
depending on your coordinate system or
how you're going to use it you can chop
that up as many times as you want
because they're not talking about
direction direction you cannot chop into
pieces
direction is always like that it's made
of a single piece and what they do they
chop direction to Pieces because they're
talking about what motion and each one
of those pieces is location and each one
is assigned a number so that you have
this coordinate system that's why they
put arrows and that's why they chop the
arrow that long Arrow they chop it into
pieces
okay so you got that that's what they're
putting in front of your eyes
and then they start giving you all this
uh
you know this word Wizardry in your ears
and that you're listening to and you say
well I can't make sense of what they're
putting in there and what this guy is
explaining of course not you're never
going to make heads or tails or
mathematics in that sense because
mathematics has nothing to do with
physics what you're looking at is a
physical thing that's hitting your eyes
that's objectively coming into your eyes
and they're asking you to interpret it
in a given way which is not what you
have in front of you what you have in
front of you is motion each one of those
segments is
location you build motion with locations
just like we do in our Universal movie
it's got an arrow
that arrow is not a static Direction
it's motion direction of motion and you
have to walk like in this case example
you have to walk two paces to the right
and three Paces North and you get to the
point which is a location which is where
you're at where the treasure chest is at
okay and again itineraries are rotated
90 degrees so they rotate it 90 degrees
remember those are itineraries and
they're to get their perpendiculars
their Dimensions because dimensions are
orthogonal to each other
okay length and height are perpendicular
to each other and so they rotate them
because what they're talking about is
not Dimensions like length width and
height you're talking about number lines
made of
locations each one with a number
assigned to it and they're rotating
these to the 90 degree angle to the
perpendicular angle meaning vertical
versus horizontal
that's what it's all about
okay
okay let's go with our uh
signed critic
and he surprised me he talks about uh
testing the hypothesis
I have no idea what he's talking about
what do you mean testing the hypothesis
okay so let's see uh and he also says
that because you know we have uh our
proposal which is the Rope hypothesis
uh which is more or less looks like this
we're saying uh this is what's between
any two atoms my fists are the atoms
here and we're saying this is what the
basic system is out there two atoms
Bound by a pair of twine threads and
they're bound because the same threads
build the atoms so everything's a single
thread in the universe okay that's
that's the hypothesis that's the
that's the proposal our assumption
that's our starting point so that people
can follow the train of thought and it
turns out this vowel says uh how does he
test the hypothesis how is he going to
test his rope hypothesis so let's listen
to him first here let me put them on
oh sorry
doing this
there he goes
he issued to be addressed in this
rebuttal is
what can it possibly mean to test a
hypothesis
notice how he just brushed over the
testable part which is a very big part
of science Testing your hypotheses I
wonder if bill has ever tested his Silly
String hypothesis or if it can even be
tested
okay so um he wants to test the
hypothesis whatever that means and then
he wants to say well Bill how do you
test your robe hypothesis how would you
test that one how do we I don't prove it
prove its existence I'm not sure exactly
what he's got in mind and so let's
clarify some issues here first of all
you know these are the Notions that
people have of what a hypothesis is this
is what people are brainwashed in high
school typically some go as far as
college and this is what the Notions
people have in their heads and what a
hypothesis is these are examples okay
first one is objectives State the
purpose
of a hypothesis upon which the project
is based all these are from official
sites okay a hypothesis is your question
in statement form
hypothesis are single tentative guesses
or a good hunches
so we have a purpose we have question we
have guesses hunches
like you know prediction because they're
gonna assume for use of devising a
theory or planning an experiment so
they're talking about some kind of
prediction that you're going to be
making
the next one says it's an assumption the
other one says it's an explanation
uh with some evidence of or and testing
behind it
all these are hypo the Notions we have
of the word hypothesis are that the
mathematicians have right out there in
ordinary speech and Mathematics
physical Theory
a hypothesis is a theory a theory is a
hypothesis there's synonym
and it's always provisional so it's
provisional it's a hypothesis but a
theory I guess is when it's not
provisional anymore when it's I guess
accepted everybody votes and says okay
now we turn the hypothesis we morph the
hypothesis into a theory
a tentative theory about the natural
world again it's a tentative Theory and
then data analysis says another fellow
so these are all the Notions people have
of what a hypothesis is and of course
nobody has any idea what a hypothesis is
because they have 100 Notions for what
it is
so we need to Define what a hypothesis
is and it's not a didn't do that
obviously he says oh how do you test the
hypothesis can we test Bill's hypothesis
and he's that I'm skipping testing the
hypothesis yeah because he's got all
these Notions I and I don't know which
one he's got in his tiny brain you know
so of course uh unless we can pick his
brain we won't know exactly what he
means by or what he understands about
our hypothesis okay so let's summarize
here these are these Notions and
objective or purpose uh an investigative
proposal or question a prediction or
testable statement an assumption or
guess an explanation a theory and data
analysis how do you like that for a
definition Huh
so are all these synonyms
do all these Notions that you see
therefore the word hypothesis are all
the same
and I would think not you know I would
if I had to bet I would say no if I take
this to the ETS to the Klingons on the
other side of the universe and I give
them all these Notions they say what do
you mean by a hypothesis bill that's
what they would tell me they would tell
me to you know go somewhere else you
know what I mean
okay so uh here's the rational version
of what a hypothesis is okay it's a a an
assumption
and assumptions include three things the
objects that you're going to use the
definitions you're going to use a key
definition this the ones that you're
going to need for your theory the
explanation that is founded upon these
assumptions and a statement of the facts
not the facts
but the statement of the facts
Mother Nature knows the facts God knows
the facts the devil knows the facts and
so does Father Universe all these guys
they know the facts they know what
happened they're out there they know
everything they know all the past
exactly how it happened
every single
um frame of the universal movie is filed
in a cabinet they have access to that
cabinet they know exactly what happened
we humans we Petty humans we little ants
we don't we don't know what happened
exactly
you were there and you saw how this guy
killed someone else you say I said it's
a fact
well you probably know it's a fact you
Pro your your notion matches father
Universe God and all these other fellows
but now you got to tell me about it you
got to tell your neighbor about it
and he's got to believe you in your word
he wasn't there he didn't see the
killing
so you said no Joey kill Johnny he said
well that's maybe you were on drugs that
day maybe you were drunk maybe maybe you
killed him and want to blame him you
know there's all sorts of uh variations
here and so so the rest of the world
will not agree with you they don't know
what the facts are so all you can do is
give you give them the statement of the
facts the facts according to your
version the
um defense attorney and the prosecutor
don't always agree on the facts so each
one gives a statement of the facts of
what they think the facts are
okay and that's different than the
actual facts of what actually happened
okay so there's a difference so we don't
talk about the facts we talk about a
statement of the facts statement of the
facts means this is your version of the
facts
doesn't mean that the other side is
going to agree completely with you some
people have as a fact that God exists
other people have doubts about that fact
and so you work with those facts we work
with our facts you know everybody's got
his own facts so we call them statement
of the facts some guy begins his
presentation saying let us assume that
God exists and the other guy says well
let us assume that God does not
so each one works with different facts
we call those statement of the facts
okay so a hypothesis sets the stage for
the explanation
that follows founded upon it and which
is called the theory okay theory is an
explanation hypothesis is an assumption
we don't test assumptions okay
um
and here it is well let me put it over
here
okay uh this is the oh sorry got the
wrong one
let me get rid of this
here's uh here's how you test the
hypothesis in science we don't test
assumptions
okay why because in fact we don't test
anything you know the there's no testing
why because testing is experiment we
don't do experiments in science let me
say that again people say you you
misspoke bill you said that we don't do
experiments in science exactly we don't
do experiments in science the only
purpose of experiments is to collect
evidence and the only purpose of
evidence is to prove meaning that you're
going to convince persuade
uh recruit people
that's the only purpose of experiment
doing an experiment like to show someone
something you're just trying to convince
them we don't do convincing in science
in science we only explain objectively
so the person understands then he can
reach his own conclusions you can
introduce evidence if you want but that
part is religion that's the one where we
try to persuade the guy to believe like
we do
okay so there's a difference there one
thing is to just State the theory the
explanation put it out there so that the
person understands a mechanism
then the other thing is to persuade him
say look I've got evidence that I'm
right
that's religion
that's what mathematical physics does
they work a lot on religion very little
on explanation in fact not at all
because all their explanations for
invisible intangible mediators of
phenomena right are all all without
exception irrational
now even they don't even qualify for
religion or like they say it's not even
wrong okay
okay so um
uh yeah religious belief opinion
knowledge and that's what testing is all
about okay you test what to test
um to to try to bring evidence
and what why why are you bringing
evidence well because you want to
convince someone okay
uh so it's irrational to test ever
existence right in science we Define
existence so you cannot say Bill prove
to me
you'll test your hypothesis meaning
prove to me that the Rope exists okay
and so this is the question for for the
self that's what he's got going through
his mind how do you test how do you
experiment
C touch hands eyes
seed touch you're going to the lab
you're going to run an experiment you're
going to test
how do you test
that which is invisible and intangible
okay
we can't see it we can't touch it but
you want to go to the lab and test
something run some kind of experiment to
prove its existence
and all you needed to do for existence
is Define the word exist
as we do which is shape that which I
shape an object right that has location
okay
so here you want to test you want to
test the hypothesis that God exists out
there
so how do we test it
I mean God apparently is invisible and
untouchable right
so how do we test that do we bring God
into a room and see if we can see him
and touch them
the ghost the spirit whatever you want
to call it
or do we Define the word exist and say
look if God is an object he already has
partly qualified for existence but in
addition he has to have a location
there's got to be distance between my
chest and his
now you have a definition that you can
use consistently and you can say look
let us assume God exists
or what do you mean by that well I mean
that God is an object and he has
location within the universe meaning
there's separation between my chest and
his now we can follow your presentation
because we understand what you're saying
but if you say oh God exists I assume
that God exists well what did you mean
by that
did you mean you're going to run the
test in the lab and see if you can see
and touch them is that what you meant
so again all you need to do is Define
the word exists and then the Rope exists
if it has physical presence if it has if
it's an object and it does qualify as an
object I hope you see an object here and
then if it has location if it has
distance with respect to other ropes and
other atoms out there and if it does if
there's separation there then it exists
by definition and so we make the
assumption
the Assumption in order to understand
the theory that follows bounded upon it
that the Rope exists meaning it's an
object and it has location
we're done
okay so there's nothing to test I'm not
going to go to the lab and see if I can
touch the rope if I can see the Rope
because it's not what I'm going to work
I'm telling you it's invisible and
intangible and you say then that's not
an object now an object is not that
which you can see or touch an object is
that which has shape the object already
had shape before you came into the room
the moon already had shape before we
were born it was an object by definition
because it had shape energy is not an
object field is not an object
um wave is not an object those do not
have shape
okay Standalone shapes
field is a dynamic concept energy is a
dynamic concept mass is a dynamic
concept plasma is a dynamic concept so
it's electricity and all those words
used by so many people out there who
call themselves
physicists
so that's where the problem is okay you
don't go in there and say well I'm going
to prove the existence of energy what
are you going to do see and touch energy
is that what you're going to do no if it
has shape then it it's an object by
definition
and you don't need to prove its
existence all you do is say look I'm
going to define the word exist and by
definition energy exists because it's a
physical object and it has uh shape and
it has location then you can talk about
the existence of energy
and also that you can talk about energy
being an object a thing
if you cannot show me if you cannot draw
energy for me um show me a picture of
energy Standalone you know and say this
is energy and point to it
you cannot even talk about the existence
of energy because you still don't have
an object which is one of the
requirements for it to have existence
okay so let's go
to the questions that people had today
uh since last time uh questions comments
okay here's the first one fellow says
sound waves have shapes magnetic fields
have shapes energies have shape
well all I can say to this fellow is uh
don't just state that do something a
little more productive you know point to
uh site on the internet you can upload
it yourself it doesn't matter you can do
it either way you can upload your own
images or you can point to an image on
the internet what we can see
uh what you're talking about how is
sound
waves right a wave having shape uh
magnetic field has shape uh energy has
shaped show us a picture an image you
know when I look up these words I don't
see any images
and the images like in the case of waves
I see a bunch of vectors those are not
images of physical things okay Vector is
a number with Direction supposedly
magnetic field again uh Mr
James Maxwell he said it's matter in
motion inside a field
so you got to show us that matter
portion that's what you got to show us
not the field field is a dynamic concept
something is moving in there and if you
don't know that well you got to read
Maxwell okay he probably didn't never
read them but he says matter in motion
that's what a field is so it's like
saying that it's a jumping kangaroo as I
like to say jumping kangaroo is not an
object a kangaroo is an object you have
to identify the kangaroo here and tell
me what is it that is motion what is
that matter that is in moving inside a
field okay and you can see that when uh
magnet attracts another one underwater
uh attracts the iron filings one at a
time and so something is moving in there
just sweeping them up and so it's very
easy to show that okay so uh you got
some homework there guy uh all you got
to do is you know uh show us pictures of
what you say have shape I mean don't say
it show us very simple
now the fellow says uh
physics describes the effects
mathematically
it doesn't explain the causes the
mechanism and never will
aha
well the problem here is that this file
is confusing physics with mathematical
physics which ain't physics okay here it
is math is doesn't explain okay math is
can only describe okay but we're talking
about mathematical physics not about
physics physics and mathematical physics
are two different things mathematical
physics and not even a religion it's not
even wrong
okay because mathematical physics only
has irrational explanations math is only
describes and does it mathematically
meaning quantitatively right and
mathematical physicists provide the most
irrational explanation they can come up
with
to uh to simple phenomena to explain
simple phenomena like you know magnetism
oh man you should see that talking about
electrons spinning around uh gravity
warping a space-time they have all this
nonsense out there particles at two
places at once it's all garbage
everything coming out of mathematical
physics is just garbage as far as an
explanation is concerned that's why they
say we don't explain of course they
don't explain they don't explain because
mathematics has no power to explain
but physics is explanational only
explanation physics rational
explanations for causes and mechanisms
that's what physics is what is it that
people want to know
what what do they want to understand and
they say well I wish I could no I wish I
could understand how gravity works
let me show you how difficult this
question is
here's my famous experiment you take a
pencil okay take a pencil you let go of
it
and it falls down
and you do it a million times it always
falls down unless there's some other
thing going on right it never goes to
the ceiling always goes to the floor
and you say oh it's so breathtaking I
cannot imagine how that works
and in three thousand four thousand five
thousand years nobody has figured it out
and all they needed to do all these
centuries is figure out what invisible
objects
are pulling or pushing this pencil
downwards something is pushing from
above something is pulling From Below
one of those two has to be
if you see there's if you say that
there's nothing there because you can't
see or touch what's below or above it
you're explaining this with black magic
you're saying nothing comes in contact
with the skin of the pen simply because
you can't see or touch it and despite
that nothing comes in contact with it
action at a distance this thing Falls
downwards always
Mother Nature is not that irrational in
fact if if I told you that I pull on the
Donkey
with a rope it was if that's kid stuff I
understand that
yeah you pull on the Rope that's tied to
the neck of the donkey of course you
pull and Donkey comes over it's
it's no mystery
only because you can see the Rope
but if I go like this go through the
motions and the donkey comes towards me
you say oh how did he do that that's
black magic
because he's got no mediator
and he's pulling on the donkey from far
away
that's called Black Magic no there had
better be a rope there an invisible
intangible rope there you cannot see or
touch it but I can't be pulling on the
donkey with nothing
and the donkey comes towards me
you know uh that's called Black Magic if
I can do that and mother nature doesn't
is not a witch she doesn't do black
magic she works with invisible
intangible mediators for those kinds of
phenomena
and until you get that through your
thick skull you won't understand how
this universe works the universe works
with invisible intangible mediators
because an object is not that which you
can see or touch it's that which has
shape it has shape but you cannot see or
touch it and that's where people have a
lot of problems with that oh I can't
deal with that yeah because every day we
think that objects are those things that
we can see or touch
not the mediators Mother Nature uses to
do her fantastic workings of the
universe okay
okay and we finally have another fellow
that's what was funny and he talks about
the law of identity which is that one at
the bottom a equals a man they broke
their heads doing this
all these philosophers you know they a
equals a he says the bare minimum you
need for any coherent expression is the
law of identity
any irrational philosophy starts with
that okay
uh yet you appear to uh decry the
simplest of rules
I'm Breaking All the Rules all the laws
of physics I get are the law is a
philosophy or whatever how can you
critique anyone uh anyone's science uh
anyone's philosophy without utilizing
the basic law of identity
and there's the law of identity uh they
broke their heads on this they they
think it's one of the pillars of
philosophy of logic a equals a
now you know why we're where we're at
today because these people are dealing
with four dimensional or number line
space time they say time can be bent and
that's gravity two particles out of the
same time in different places and
because a equals a
laughs
okay with that I'll see you next Sunday
we'll see